[Music]
in this week's original we present the
fifth part of a now legendary alien film
series the talk is of course about
predator prey which will be released
this summer and is a sort of
quasi-reboot of the franchise this video
will tell you everything you need to
know about the release and what kind of
information is known at all
with predator prey the next installment
of the successful science fiction
franchise has finally been released
after a long wait it was only at the end
of last year that the official title
prey was revealed at all before that the
movie was only known under its working
title skulls responsible for the
production is none other than town
cloverfield lane director dan traxenberg
apart from then cloverfield lane the 40
year old american has not really had
many commitments as directors so far but
was obviously able to convince those
responsible at disney and 20th century
fox with the aforementioned blockbuster
and individual episodes of black mirror
for example anyone who has followed the
production of the uncharted film
adaption will also recognize trackenberg
as he was one of the many directors who
applied for the project the script was
written by jack ryan producer patrick
ayson and is more or less conceived as a
reboot of the film series ace and his
colleague john davis have been
developing the idea for predator 5
behind the scenes for years allegedly
even during the production of the
predator the new project has now been
finalized since september and is waiting
for the right time for release in the
summer of 2022
the way in which the film is to be
distributed is not met with great
enthusiasm by all fans however as those
responsible confirmed last november
praise to hit the streaming service hulu
which significantly reduced the
likelihood of a theatrical release that
many had hoped for a parallel release
for theaters and home theaters has not
been specifically ruled out but if you
look at the approach of other hulu
releases you should not count on a
theatrical release internationally the
movie will be available on disney plus
unfortunately those responsible are
keeping any footage of predator 500 raps
there's a single image from november
12th but it only shows the main
character nero with bow and arrow and
the predator indistinctly in the
background
the action takes place about 300 years
in the past and is briefly about how the
warrior naru wants to protect her tribe
the comanche people from the alien
creatures at all costs the brand new
setting makes it clear that the entire
movie series is daring to make a fresh
start as it is quite risky to set the
story this far in the past after all
this automatically takes us away from
the practice of the new films to somehow
reproduce the original from 1987 because
let's be honest that's never really
worked very well so far it is precisely
this reboot that could now give this
somewhat discredited franchise a new
chance to win over the fan community
even if prequels and reboots are not
necessarily easier to produce than crude
sequels the deliberate distance to the
original makes it possible to dive
deeper into the original story of the
hunting aliens in addition the setting
of hundreds of years ago is something
completely new many however rightly
wonder how a native american wants to
fight the dangerous creatures without
modern weapons exactly when the first
encounter between aliens and humans took
place cannot be determined however in
prey we are roughly in the period in
which the alien creatures first found
their way to earth perhaps it was even
the case that naru is the very first
human to encounter the predators and
thus had a decisive influence on their
future behavior to its humans looking
back at the 1987 original it can already
be seen there that the creatures are
best eliminated with simple but
effective traps and the bigger gun is
not always the proper means of choice
for successful combat in general there
are hardly any limits to prey after all
the setting of nearly 300 years ago
offers countless creative and new
possibilities to fight against the
predators one thing is clear though if
prey flops as badly with fans and
critics as the predator did it will
probably be the last movie in the
franchise
since the conclusion of shooting in
september we also know quite a bit about
the cast the spotlight is on 23 year old
leading actress amber mid thunder who
being the daughter of an actor and a
stunned woman has already appeared in
movies as a child and is accordingly not
an absolute newcomer in recent years for
example she has appeared in four
episodes of fargo her most recent film
was the netflix blockbuster the eyes
wrote where she got to perform alongside
liam neeson and lawrence fishburne the
latter actor is an old brother veteran
himself also joining the cast is former
pro basketball player dan de liegra who
has been pursuing his acting career for
a few years now the six foot nine tall
athlete featured in the walking dead as
well as in american horror stories and
is looking forward to his first big
movie appearance his exact role is
currently unknown but due to his
tremendous height we see de liegro
rather in the role of the predator
however this is all still pure
speculation and neither confirmed nor
denied also new to the cast is dakota
beavers in a still unknown part
otherwise surprisingly little is known
about the cast which would of course
also mean that they intend to surprise
us with even bigger names against
appearance by arnold schwarzenegger
which is always vehemently demanded in
every sequel is unfortunately more than
unlikely due to the timeline in addition
this star of the first part had already
rejected his plan returned to the
franchise in the script of the previous
film because he felt that the designated
guest role was too minor
and that's it again with our latest
original will you give the film a shot
despite its streaming release and do you
think the unusual plot based way back in
the past could be a breakthrough or are
you rather of the opinion that the old
idea will flop feel free to let us know
your thoughts and feelings in the
comment section see you next time
[Music]
you